I'm or sort of the health side first you
have to see have a background in science
you've been watching this play out you
know on Twitter and in headlines etc
what's your general sense as to what's
happened and kind of where we are with
the virus right now well I've spent the
entire pandemic thinking in two weeks
I'll know it's just been in two weeks
I'll know so I first at first got you
know there's always something coming out
of the Chinese wet market that's right
there's always those guys will eat
anything that Wiggles right and and so
what caught my attention is the minute
they shut down Wuhan and I said oh my
god we just shattered the supply chains
right so I started reaching out to
friends I got I got an email from
Einhorn who's been so generous with this
time a Steven Roach who's been so
generous with this time and we started
sort of swapping war stories trying to
figure it out what what did it mean but
I was convinced that you can't shut down
a major region of China without
destroying the global supply chain now
it hasn't been as bad as I thought I
thought we'd see but but but I ran into
tons of people who said we're not
getting the chips we need we're not
getting this we're not getting that
there could be a delayed reaction
there's even theories out there they
said they shut everything down so no one
would be demanding the supplies right
what an interesting thesis that is right
now I'll entertain any idea until I
shoot at them so in any event the guy
who I think got it right was again one
of your former interviewees Jim Bianco
he was on it fast and furious and so
we're swapping a lot of emails mostly
one direction mostly him just tell me
stuff for me going I agree um and and I
think it's been devastating and it
reminds me it's like it's like someone
put up stick of dynamite in the turkey
blew it up and then someone else came
along put it back together now right it
doesn't work that way so I think we
destroyed the global economy in a very
big way and I think that the people who
think we're just gonna reassemble it are
just are dreaming I could be wrong but I
certainly is a strong opinion Bianco
said one day on Twitter and he got
Court he said you know 90% recoveries a
disaster and people said what are you
greedy what are you and I I had to chime
in and I said 90% recovery means 10%
drop in GDP that's a disaster and so and
so yeah so I think I think we're gonna
have lots of missing jobs that don't
ever come back you can't run a
restaurant at 50% capacity you can't run
a movie theater feminists watch with
masks on and so the only way we come
back is everyone just says screw it me
and the world which by the way I think
they've collectively are trying to do
right one of the questions I'm trying to
understand is why about two weeks ago
sudden with no change in the biomedical
story opposite that just became a now
we're gonna open up and I'm gonna what
was that right there was no you know
all-clear signal that was put out there
do you think it had to do with just it
literally got warmer in various areas so
like literally just springtime hit maybe
it could also be remember Arab Spring
remember what caused Arab Spring
some Tunisian Guy'd lit himself on fire
just one flammable Tunisian and that
triggered and so it could be something
like the that blonde relatively hot a
hair stylist who said I'm not closing
and it could be as hell yeah you know
the shadow like Lexington and Concord
you know who knows what but it just
changed it just changed and all of a
sudden people stopped wearing masks
except in logical places so you see him
at the store but not walking down the
street so there's just a sea change that
occurred it was it was like people just
Randy there a lot of people who are
critical saying that's really selfish to
do that I'm going these people don't
know how they're gonna feed their kids
there's nothing nothing selfish about
that and so it's real easy to sit there
with a paycheck and criticize people who
are and we know what was the stat it's
not like 40% of the people couldn't put
400 dollars together if they had to
write those people now can't we can't
put 50 cents together well I think
you're bringing up a couple issues right
so the first is
one of the things that I'm personally
interesting your opinion right is you
spend all day looking at science and you
come from a mindset where there's a
hypothesis you test it and see they're
correct or it's not you move on you kind
of rinse and repeat that process over
and over again we saw with the virus was
a number of people who they put forth
these models that I'll call them
hypothesis right because no one really
knew what was gonna happen but they were
they were trying to predict how bad
could this be and you'd see models that
said you know worst case base case and
best case type situations what I think
now is transpired is we've got you know
a month or two months of data in the
lock down and people are saying wait a
second you're telling me that you know
an order of magnitude less people have
actually died than you originally said
right and there's almost like this shock
and awe factor if people were anchored
on such big numbers you know millions of
Americans dying and now all of a sudden
they see the numbers and by the way
there are people who have died right
there's a lot of people who have died
actually
it's just nearly as much and it looks
actually like a small number compared to
what the original predictions were and
you think that like the psychology of
that plays into people's been like look
open damn you know economy up yeah you
lied to us I think is another way of
putting it I don't know if this is true
yet so one of the things I'm I will be
watching for and I've been thinking
about is is if the shutdown really did
heroic things to stop the spread well
first and foremost you're gonna have to
explain why other regions of the world
are in a killing field right so we're
not I heard Mexico has three times as
many cases you know BFD it's still not a
big number and and you know I know
suppose Allison stop having cases but
everyone said ah China just a bunch of
liars you know we can write them off
enough then you go boom maybe they're
not right maybe the damn thing is
stopped maybe it ran its course in China
and and so now so the other problem we
have is I've been talking to a lot of
biochemist one of my former students is
up biochemist at Harvard now and he and
I spent hours on the phone chatting with
him about how the virus work
and how it you know gets the RNA into
the cells and how the incubation this
guy's glued to it and he was pretty
nervous about the whole thing so I can't
say that the that the serious
biochemists weren't nervous about it but
I was waiting for the numbers to
unequivocally unambiguously exceed
anything normal so when it was in five
thousand or ten thousand we're still sub
flu numbers now I think we're above flu
numbers but there's a there's a there's
a problem with the data being so bad so
the data is bad at two levels first of
all what's the comorbidity at this point
in time some eighty seven-year-old guy
crashes his motorcycle they're calling
it covered when some guy dies my heart
attack because he had kovin is it really
a code of death if he had gotten simply
a mild case the fluid would have died
and so you don't know how to count
second of all I've heard there's over 90
different tests now I got tested because
I've been feeling crummy for a while I
said why not
my son had and he said why not we went
got tested and they did it all wrong
they did it all wrong they you know if
you do that the nasal tests they're
supposed to jam it back there to the
point where you feel like an Egyptian
mommy in the making right and there's a
name for when they pull the brains out
through your nose and and they just
swapped it around her nose and that was
it I go that's not going to test for
anything but 90 different tests you know
you got Elizabeth Holmes probably
running tests out there and so it's
gonna be garbage data right they're all
testing for different markers I you can
have Corona flavored RNA in there and
it's testing positive is it four base
pairs five base pairs and and and that
my former students said you know they
don't yet have a good one doing a lot of
statistical analysis then you got that
guy Neil Ferguson who was out there
bullshitting to to oppress his his his
38 year old girlfriend but it's even
worse than that turns out she's a sort
of a as I understand it a professional
activist
so he she's out there you know with all
these because it's often you one'll neo
on serious action out of this chick now
and so uh and so his his numbers that
apparently got entire nations to change
their policy was because he want to get
laid right I mean is that destroy the
nation by the way